thank you so much for having me I'm a
little bit surprised to be honest I
don't think I'm supposed to be a
stand-up comedian
so I'm sorry like this isn't my
childhood dream my childhood dream was
to be in the WNBA yeah it's the NBA for
her pleasure
when I was in seventh grade I got a
women's basketball for Christmas I
immediately realized I could palmate and
I was like all right blame ball for the
rest of my life my my voice is deep back
then I also realized that I have really
large hands for a female thanks you know
what they say about a lady with big
hands gross
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I'm a FEMINIST I've that's good you like
this joke I've noticed a lot of people
are claiming to be feminists but I don't
think you're real feminists unless you
know all of the WNBA teams you guys want
to learn the WNBA teams I mean we're
here alright here they are LA Sparks in
New York Liberty Minnesota Lynx in
Phoenix Mercury Indiana Fever Dallas
Wings in San Antonio Stars Connecticut
Sun Seattle storm Atlanta dream in
Chicago's guy if you put all the teams
in a singing list you become a feminist
thank you
also the Washington Mystics they don't
fit I'm a professional singer you guys
want to marry your mom when you were
younger I wanted to marry my mom so hard
because when you're younger adults say
when you get older you're gonna marry
who you love and I was like well I love
mom there we go cue the wedding bells
and that's a cute and innocent thought
at least it was until my parents got a
divorce it was back on the table
[Applause]
[Music]
pick my siblings who walk by on like hey
uh do mom say anything about me always
flirting with me making me dinner
picking me up dropping me off not to be
gay but I'm a lesbian
thank you that's actually the first time
I've ever said that so thank you so much
hey I was like you know what I'm gonna
come out when I can get to Burbank in
front of a studio audience in front of
Conan and Auntie and Molly I am gay and
I'm Irish and I hate parades I have a
lot of gay friends because it's required
and my friend he asked me for some
advice he was gonna come out to his 97
year old grandma he's like mo are you
out to your grandparents I was like no
man no one's out to their grandparents I
just wait it out you'll be fine
I had a fun text from my friend in the
middle of the night
another friend it was a photo of his
penis yeah see straight girls I'm just
like you I get the dick fix
he accidentally sent it to me he was
trying to send it to his girlfriend
Molly mo LLY my name is mo mo he is
lucky one more letter some people get it
you would have been sending a photo of
his poorly lit penis to M om which I'm
pretty sure spells mom yeah can you
imagine getting that text oh it's Jeremy
you didn't forget my birthday after all
[Applause]
but my friend he was begging me he's
like you have to delete that photo off
your phone I'm like what kind of lesbian
just keeps dick pics on her phone but
yeah like every time he calls it shows
up
[Applause]
you